but the thing is what would you want me
to do i'm supposed to be honest
about your manager
but i played the game i played the game
with rules and integrity you're just
being a tribal idiot i can't help it
you're just being a tribal leader i
don't care that's what i am it's fine
okay well look that means you must
acknowledge it i'm not gonna sit here on
this channel and go oh yeah with chelsea
a bigger be a man of truth and principle
rather than just a bonehead
right
[Music]
oh really
well oh really
[Laughter]
it feels malicious issue
why because if we've been doing this at
any point over the last 30 years i felt
i'd be really happy to see you but this
season i'm slightly concerned you should
be there's many things from things have
changed the lab bible who do i need to
talk to here
you now is not ideal they put me in
front of tyre
you think this is bad
that's a nightmare
yeah spurs will finish above chelsea
this season
three two one
oh gosh
to be the man i want to be you can't
you've got to go that way i have to go
yeah
any self-respect but you know for the
first time in 30 years i'm not gonna go
there so i'm gonna go to disagree
all right and it's basically because
we've got conte we've got you know
finished the season so well you signed
some important players
and
chelsea in a bit of a mess at the moment
right we don't know the time recorded we
don't know what i mean that felt very
aggressive the way but yeah
you you're on you're definitely a little
bit weird what's going on chelsea you're
not the the the abramovich chelsea more
you're todd bowley which is very
different yeah i agree i agree there
doesn't seem to be a strategy there
doesn't seem to be this overarching
ambition it seems to be a football
manager do you know the word
well
scattergun
that's what i'm gonna go with it's a
scattergun approach
chance fans so he's available do you
want him yeah do you need him it's not
the point he's available and that seems
to be what we're doing so yeah i'm
worried about this season i'm really not
looking forward to it i'm worried about
you as well i think that you're going to
be a
real
real threat a thorn in our side we're
playing you so early which is not ideal
at all but
and this is what i'm clinging on to and
that is why my point is firmly placed on
this side of the table you're tottenham
you are tottenham and therefore the
conversation becomes the power
of kante is huge right he kryptonite is
it opposite of tottenham isn't it but
but i don't think that conte ism as an
ideology
can overwhelm spursi ism
i think spursism as an ideology is going
to be too strong for even the power
force of context it can't be a real
thing but no spurs it's a real thing
because people have talked into
existence we've seen it i know we've
seen it i know right i know and i
understand it you've been there i've
seen it i know it better than you know
it right but it can't be a real thing
right it's just a coincidence it's just
a series of unfortunate events that
people have grouped up and labelled
spursy this is the most fearful i've
ever been of tottenham but we're not
clinging on to i'm clinging on to
tottenham
being tottenham and
kante's gone in november no i mean this
is he's all i mean this is what people
want they hate the fact that conte is at
tottenham
everybody they don't understand it they
can't figure out what tottenham is in
the club
there isn't there isn't an institution
in the entire world that i have more
antipathy towards in tottenham hotspot i
i appreciate it i've never been more
comfortable as a spurs fan as i am right
now ever
at this point there's no reason why
spurs fans shouldn't be super optimistic
and i'm not just saying optimistic like
finishing top four we should be looking
up with that in mind though there's one
thing that's given me a bit of hope why
you why is that point not there because
tottenham oh so you believe it i i live
through it i understand it you're you're
schooled you're hurt yeah of course yeah
yeah but i think he's all gone mad at
chelsea if you want to explore this why
don't why are we hearing todd bowdy's
name so much it shouldn't be do you
wanna hear john know why he's negomania
because he's mad yeah because in their
right mind you know you're a rich dude
from california or whatever right and
you know you live a great life you've
then bought a london football club
that's great
why on earth are you supporting director
you've never worked in european sport
before in your life you know nothing
about football suddenly you're dealing
with transfers i guarantee you this
a year ago if you went up to
todd bowie bowling went wait what do you
reckon to mark cuckerella
what what's that
all of a sudden he's like we need
cucarella and the thing is you don't
need him that's that's that's it and
he's wrong in terms of talking about top
four obviously there's two that don't
need to be mentioned here right in
whatever order i'm not talking about
winter league but city liverpool in
toppo whatever of course i think
tottenham make it i really do into the
top four i'm talking and then it's a
question of can chelsea finish it by
tottenham
possibly chelsea needs to battle it out
with manchester united west ham and
arsenal and in that fight
i feel like we can win yeah i mean as
much as i've got no time for chelsea
i would take that all day right now the
fort of arsenal even going near the top
four makes me sick so if it's chelsea
it's chelsea we're gonna do that we're
gonna do what you hated we're about to
bond massively over chelsea finishing
the top five we're not gonna bond
we're not gonna bond over chelsea at all
chelsea are a bigger club than tottenham
hotspur
three two one
i mean we need another table here i need
i need to go here
it's like this this you can't strongly
disagree with that you can say what i
want i mean i mean you can yeah by that
look you can apply any logic you want
but by whatever rationale you're using
you'll be correct what give what so what
what is the rationale how do we argue
this i think it's i think it's obvious
firstly i think it's just obvious
sometimes you don't need to go into like
the workings you don't always need to
see the workings out to know the answer
but the thing is what would you want me
to do i'm supposed to be honest
about your manager
but i played the game i played the game
with rules and integrity you're just
being a tribal idiot i can't help it
[Laughter]
um
look tell me why i taught them a bigger
club in chelsea then just this will be
fun this will be really entertaining
tell me why tottenham are a bigger club
in charlotte look the thing is is that
you this is unfair this question
because
i didn't write the questions i wasn't
happy with the first letting them know
no i've made my feelings known to the
love bible already the very first
question really put my nose out jen but
i roll with the punches because i'm
professional i'd ask you to do the same
without abramovich
which is essentially become a brand
abramovich fc then
there's no chance that chelsea
chelsea spent so so much time outside
the top division and should we play a
game then okay you so you're about you
want to do a brandon [ __ ] okay
let's analyze think about that last 20
years and let's analyze the the ten
years pre-abramovich well both of us so
you're you're you're pretty brave i
didn't bring a bravery up yeah but you
knew i would say a brown [ __ ] right and
then you knew and you knew you knew it
no no wait you had you knew in the
locker you knew you had that 10 years
before bravo [ __ ] right and then then
you said you can't mention bill nick so
you've taken everything away from me
look if you want to you you've brought
brahmavir all right and you saying that
abramovic isn't
an argument or isn't relevant when he's
only just left of course he is yeah yeah
of course he is but equally i would say
no it's financially dope successfully
it's not real no not the 10 years prior
to felt cheap can you explain to me then
why totten didn't win at stanford bridge
for
30 years including 10 years prior to
abramovic just do you know do you know
the winning goal scorer lucky it went
delhi ali do you know who it was before
that delhi ali squad sheringham no gary
lineker gary lineker so the winners at
stanford bridge for top of the players
were scored gary lineker 1990 delhi
alley 2017 or whatever
that isn't an abramovich jira that's
partly in the brand of europa but it
isn't and their brand is defined yeah
but but before that everything's
different
you nearly went out of business let's
say ken bates to come and save your club
all right tori what's somebody with
anything what are you some mad captains
just a big club doesn't go out of
business me does it i think lots of
clubs have struggled with financial
issues yeah i don't think that's it i
don't think that's a mad
i think that if that's your idea there
was not a difference there's not there
was not much difference before you were
finally
doped and cheated your way to all the
trophies you won there was not much
difference between that okay let's try
and let's just try and answer the
question do i have how how are tottenham
bigger than chelsea today
you've got to use words
[Laughter]
look
you can't just look at me nobody looks
like punctuation
you can't you can't
obviously after the last 20 years so
just put your he's just left he's just
left okay so who's the big club today in
i'm not going to say just just to put it
out there chelsea won two european cups
london have one none the score is
chelsea two london nil
how can chelsea not be a bigger club but
anyone can do that you're lucky enough
to get a brand which is the same man i
think it's a bigger club
than chelsea because they've won more in
the last 10 years tottenham fans you
being one of them you think you're a big
club because your great granddad saw you
in a double your great granddad saw you
in the double well today you tell me
that you're a big club because your
great-grandmother my dad my dad saw us
when the double actually worried
but must have been young
uh look it's it's a difficult question
the tricky one no it's the very
definition of an easy question this
isn't this isn't a difficult question
i feel like i've moved my way for it
fairly well
and uh let's move on
i don't need to do that i think that you
have we have to come up with a
resolution
anything i say
how many trophies you want how many
trophies let me show you but do you know
what you've done though you've optimized
your entire personality here people are
going to look at you in a different way
you need to be a man of honor please
support you think i'll come across
better if i go to chelsea or a bigger
club
you'll have honor it's the eyes of
chelsea
if you do the right thing here you're
allowed to move that that isn't that
isn't fixed that isn't in concrete
[Laughter]
i'm moving it harry kane
is the best striker in premier league
history
three
two
one
i like that
man of honor i am a man of honor
original you're just coming across as
some charlatan i'm not i'm gonna i'm
gonna be honest now i'm actually i'm
actually looking at you through a
different lens rory i'm gonna tell the
truth now start from now all right okay
starting from now okay
can we can we just make a point right
this would be good for uh
this is about our common bond
but don't try and bond with me now
you like my answer you might bother with
me before
we know he's better than tyrion reed
right
we know that you've got that on camera
you can you can clip that up he's better
than
look at look at the stats some more
goals i think i think what's his job
what's his job he's go score scores and
terry i mean
[Music]
he isn't
the best to have ever done in the
premier league why because there are
better players that have done it in the
premier league name one
you tyrion really shira
no i would i would just i would have a
conversation about aguero but i will i
say the other two are better
all right well sure he hasn't broke his
record but once he's done that it's
categorically the best striker that the
premier league has ever seen shira's 260
yeah kane won't won't course he wrote
willie yeah
260. yeah
i think i think you'll go off do you
know what's a big issue here silver
seriously but see that isn't it that's
not saying tottenham including kane no
no but we've established earlier that
tottenham exists but great it's very
hard for kane to do that no but great
players inspire their team to
victories that's the point of a great
player you know if you say i never did
you agree with newcastle do you agree
that
stewart ripley a premier league winner
he made he made mike newell a premier
league winner no you're not you're a
member you're being selective and you're
a member of how much that's the backbone
yeah they spend a lot of money but he
bought the title he won the title for
them
he was the reason they won the title he
was the reason when you think of great
players that's what they do diego
maradona is a great player he won his
team world cup i just don't think he
gets the credit he deserves that's
that's it because of silverware you know
no it's because he plays he'd won a
world cup with england which he probably
should have done if he'd won a euros
with england which he probably should
have done people would look at him
through a very different lens
his problem is this a fair comment about
kane when it really matters he bottles
it he this is he has disappeared in
certain finals but he he that in itself
that in itself makes him not but the the
champions league final he was injured
and he was played plus team arsenal's
play he wasn't fit he was never never
not you ever seen david louise playing
the champions league final against
munich he played one leg scored a
penalty he's unbelievable so winners a
winner's mentality it's a great
all right you can you can we will agree
second then
we will agree second but do you know
what i would concede to you it's a bit
natasha benningfield his story is still
unwritten
yeah so
so
it could
it look
dude i do appreciate it he's amazing i
do i do think if he wins a premier
league title in his in his career is
that enough just to get that it won't be
the best but say say this happens say he
brings a friend
so he wins a premier league say win the
premier league and becomes premier
league top goal scorer ever yeah say
those two things happen but maybe
national success as well
i do think that cain is then in with
because a shout out of being the best
yeah because we've seen what angry's
done and we've seen what shira's done
there's still time for kane to do it do
you know what i don't
i don't think
i don't think he's ever had i don't
think harry kane has ever had you know
those moments those capturing moments
that tyrion re had and i know that isn't
how you define a footballer but
yeah like sierra enrique riori was silk
wasn't he he was actual silk he was
right
it was all right i don't think harry
kane could be described as silk
he's technically
woven he's technically better than both
of those players he's technically better
than both his passing range he's all
around he's all around players he's
technically a better footballer than
harry than alashiro i give you that he's
technically a better footballer he might
not be a better striker but look i do i
do think that he is
an outrageously talented footballer and
i do believe that there is still a lot
to come so who knows if he leaves this
is what he could do
honestly when
if he leaves if he leaves tottenham he
could go here
exactly
chelsea
will win their next trophy
before spurs win their next trophy three
two one i i don't i think i could see
history teaches us about the future no
history teaches us about the future
chelsea will win silverware before
tottenham like that's it's not about who
look totally finished above chelsea in
the league this season probably but
who's more likely to win silverware the
answer is always chelsea chelsea are
always more likely to recruit silverware
when you're talking i think if i'm right
about where chelsea are going you won't
win a trophy
10 10 or 15 years okay if you're right
but look at the facts look at the facts
the way they are you're you're feeling
those facts you're passed away the
reality
you must you must agree that chelsea are
more likely to win silverware because we
we have proved it two league cups since
1991 yeah but that was all
you had
right that's what you're talking about
now you've got todd bowie this guy
you've had 10 managers more in fact that
have won nothing chelsea are going
through a slight slightly turbulent era
but of course we're more likely to win
silverware you wouldn't be surprised if
chelsea win last season as i said before
last season we won eight games at home
still won two pieces of silver
did you yeah best club in the world mate
they both account they're still
they count for you no you they could
they definitely count for you if we won
a super club would they ever everybody
would get in the super cup yeah i
appreciate that but that doesn't count
after you've done it oh you're
somehow without if you take the champion
league out of that that equation if
spurs won the super cup no one be going
all right
stop chelsea chelsea win silverware no
club over the past two decades has won
more individual trophies in chelsea
because you've spent 1.6 billion pounds
we get it as a club
as a club
go back to 1997 then when the when the
drought ended
19 we won five trophies under the army's
management
brought five trophies in one team but
just a few seasons before 97 we were
winning trophies abramovic came in well
wait wait you wanted to fake up in 91.
that's pretty good
yeah that's that's a trophy in it yeah
but when you say a few years that was
that was like over half a decade before
and then when was the one before that
long time long time so you're not was it
was european countries and dave knight
is when the year ends in one 84 so it's
a trophy a decade
and nothing since nothing since
08 yeah
come on you can't honestly believe that
history teaches about the future that's
why you study but it doesn't it doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't it tells you scrap
it scrape the curriculum the flab says
listen in the next 10 years based on how
well spurs are set up now how massively
financially
uh
secure we are how the stadium is
bringing money in
we're back in kante we're giving him
what he wants this is the thing about
kante as well remember i stand to leave
he's not gonna back him to get fed up
and look what happened this season
no no
this is the new problem this is the new
tottenham but you can never until it
wins until it happens
it hasn't happened so you need people
we're asking about that so
hypothetically today who's more likely
to win real silverware the answer is
chelsea if it is anymore if tottenham if
tottenham win two trophies this season
we're having this conversation at the
beginning of next season tottenham two
trophies this year qualify for the
european cup again chelsea finish eighth
then we can have a different
conversation but as of today
it is crazy to suggest that two of them
are more suited to winter silverware if
we haven't done in ten years i'll
apologize in ten years i'll take it back
yeah there is no way you're mate you
you're a mug this is pointless no this
is why you're not you're not you're just
voting on everything everything here
with your heart i'm not being i'm not
i'm saying generally i feel supposed to
set up much better than chelsea do you
know in the comments of this video i
think that i'm going to get sick
i'm going to get stick but i have the
moral victory there is a moral victory
for me people think that you've won but
the moral village i generally don't
agree no because i can leave this
building with my head held high i can
walk out into london's fashionable west
end with my head held high what are you
going to do you're going to have to like
scurry out of
scurry out of here embarrassed put the
hood up look spurs are set up spurs are
set up for success it might not happen
but we're in a better place in chelsea
you have been shambolic today and on
this thing in particular on this bit in
particular you've been really really bad
you wait you wait just wait and see
get out
seriously get out scurry off put your
hood up
because you cannot leave here with your
head rory wait and see the moral victory
is mine wait and see you can have the
moral victory i'll have the trophies at
the end of the season no you won't you
never do you never will the news hotline
will heungman's son
is a better player than all of chelsea's
forwards
three
two
one
all of them uh there's one get out of
jail card here for chelsea it's not a
disagreement it's one
thing there is one player
there is one player who is it raheem
sterling why is it there is one player
like if listen if chelsea hadn't signed
raheem sterling i'd be over here
chelsea's forward line is pitiful it's
pitiful so
that's an option christian pulisic
so average distinctly average can't keep
fit just nothing about him zis i quite
like scored an amazing goal against you
that's not the best i've ever seen
actually no that ping no no for chelsea
yeah
he loves the golden spurs for sure
but in terms of sterling or son son is
amazing i rate him so highly i really do
i think he's dazzling footballer
but sterling is class man
i don't i don't think there's many
people that have picked sterling over so
if you had the choice of signing i don't
think you would either last season but
it's important that we acknowledge
hunminson's career over the past
since since since 2015-16 you've got to
acknowledge rahim sterling's for the
same amount of time last season
sean had a better season than sterling
but that doesn't make him a better
player it makes him have it means he had
a better season raheem sterling over
since 2016. ram sterling's won four out
of five leagues yeah with manchester
city yes he's intentionally
naturally doing that with man city
you're comparing the players no but you
can't you can't go with manchester
united
you wouldn't take this impression if you
had a choice between the two you take
something
i do i definitely
definitely taste that there's no chance
there's not much point of me being here
if you tell me what i'm saying
you've been telling me what to say
right sterling is an overall best
footballer than him
four out of the last five leagues you
can't go yeah but man city because
getting in the man city team is
impressive being simon it's just being
sacked how good can he be if he's been
if he's just they've sold him to a
driver
i'm telling you they were they put the
contract on the thing they just couldn't
guarantee him game time and he wanted
guarantees well he's so he's not good
enough
anyone game time he's a principal from
guardiola one i agree with he goes he
likes maybe actually problems
is that an issue though human had a
sensational season he was virtually
unplayable last year but we have to be
more intelligent than to define a player
by one season it's not one season mate
he's it would be like me saying that
harry kane was rubbish if we were having
this conversation in december okay to
rubbish football really because he just
had a bad few months
there's no one watching this that would
choose choose sterling over son and
someone plays number nine much better he
plays the left wing he's a better number
nine i agree i think he's better number
nine and
what does starting really offer you your
forward goals galore how many goals are
going to score this season no but you
asked me what he yeah
what's he going to offer more that's
what son does okay just let me
demonstrate this point
chelsea last season our top goalscorer
in the league was mason mount with 11.
yeah the season before was georginio
with eight raheem sterling gonna score
14 isn't he minimum was that is that
enough
to rank him better than son sonny sonnet
chelsea would score what 25 i mean
scoring goals at chelsea when you're not
being provided by harry kane and and
killer cevsky or whatever is is a lot
harder but there is no way that if you
look at raheem stoney's career and you
look at who minson's career and you
deduce who is a better player the answer
is raheem sterling by distance by
distance yeah but answers the the answer
should be is who would you rather want a
team no one is picking do you know how
different it is
to be do you know how difficult it is to
be an integral part of a pep guardiola
team for half a decade no not fair
enough well i'm not saying he's not a
good player i'm just saying
right at this time if you had to choose
one over the other it'd be some if you
were basing it solely on last season but
i'm more intelligent than that man
yeah you know you you know you need to
look up you need to look at the season
you need to look at somebody he's
consistently done it through multiple
transitions at spurs look at last season
picked consistently by mourinho
look at last season then look at the
last five seasons find you a man that
can do both look at last season look at
the previous four seasons son has been
consistent through the last five seasons
four out of five leagues were won by
raheem sterling manchester city but
you're dismissing that as if so is
virgil van dijk no good because he won a
league at liverpool if he'd be better if
he did it at tottenham
and it like rallied like he's a great
manager
because he gets he does it with all that
all the money go and do it with burnley
come to spurs and dick no dedicate it
rachel sterling has been an integral
part of vital cog
in
pep guardiola's machine that is probably
the best football team ever created
raheem sterling has been a vital part of
that
no one watching this agrees with you
that's not what i've always been looking
i've already told you i'll get slandered
but i've also told you i've got the
moral victory both spurs and chelsea
will finish above arsenal this season
three two one
definitely
i can't um
i can't stand them
i don't care where spurs finish as long
as it's above arsenal do you still think
arsenal are cowards what do you think
the pirates or ronaldo
again one of the best players ever to
play in the premier league